vous êtes pour ugo
monye d'abord j'ai acheté des carambars
et puis ça a compté dix ans il est en ce
moment là j'en achète assez souvent et
puis ça coule de 20 centimes et ils sont
pas plus grand et je connus picsou à à
358 me lance je le connais à 4
les schtroumpfs les kinder surprise a un
peu augmenté
de francs 50 au moins avant c'était pas
cher c'était 40 centimes le rugby ça le
bâton de réglisse et maintenant c'est 80
centimes j'ai acheté une boîte de
pétards qui a coûté un franc en
abaissant je vais acheter et quand je
suis revenue le 2 ou 3 jours après royal
avait dit c'est ça coûtait de francs
c'est un vrai scandale alors que
protester oui atteint l'enchère